The Joe Rogan experience.
Sometimes you don't find someone for a long time and then when you do,
it changes your whole life.
You find someone,
maybe it's just a youtube video and it's you saying it's still your
motherfucking set and it's you just pushing people and telling people to go get
after it and people see that and all of a sudden it's like they get goosebumps.
Their heart starts racing.
It's like you gave them a drug,
like you gave them fuel and then then they want to change their life and then
they want to watch you tomorrow and then they want to watch you when they're at
lunch break.
They're going to want you,
they're taking a shit in other watch you on their phone,
but that's this fuel and you literally can change a person's life through that
because we need each other.
I mean this is,
it's one more piece of evidence that we need each other.
And then we have this sort of very strange,
loose,
fitted community of all human beings together.
When someone like you does something that's exceptional and says something
that's exceptional and has these inspirational words,
he can change a person's whole life,
changed their whole path,
change who they are.
I've gotten so many messages from people that say I lost 130 pounds.
You know,
I did this,
I got off sugar.
I'm,
I'm fucking running every day.
I hit the gym five days a week.
Now I'm,
I'm a different person.
I'm drinking water,
I'm exercise that,
I take vitamins,
I'm eating healthy,
I've got more juice,
I've got more energy.
My whole life is different now.
I'm almost positive.
Yeah.
It happens all the time.
How does that make you feel?
Obligated,
you know?
No,
I didn't know.
What exactly do you feel like you have to kill?
You can't fail.
You can't cause man,
you got all these people looking up to you.
Yeah.
I don't want that.
I definitely don't want anybody looking up to me.
But I do like people being inspired and if people get inspired by me,
I'm happy.
But uh,
you know,
they do joke
and you can't help.
You can't help.
But think I don't want it.
I mean,
I don't,
I always say it all the time.
Yeah.
I'm no buddy.
I'm going way,
no,
look at me,
man.
I'm looking at,
I talk about a higher power.
Look at the higher power,
man.
Don't look at me.
We fucking need each other,
man.
We all need each other.
We really do.
There's something beautiful about that though.
They like,
he can't just go it alone.
You really do need each other.
And like if you accomplish everything you ever wanted to accomplish,
but nobody's there for with you.
Nobody cares.
Nobody likes you had told me and shit,
it's useless.
Absolutely.
Like love is the most important thing.
And that sounds so cliche,
but without love,
it's all useless.
It's all useless.
There's no personal satisfaction and accomplishments.
If nobody loves you,
you're not going to enjoy it.
Yeah.
At least your family.
Everybody
good.
And the more you can spread positive energy,
the more people will love you,
the more you'll have that community of,
you know,
that's,
that's what I was just like,
I tell you to and ever expect to even,
you know,
live past 40 I people I always think about I'm here.
I'm the little kid that used to,
um,
hide in the closet when I,
I would hear my dad's keys rattling the door or pointless car pull up in the
alley behind the calls that are trying to hide me.
And I just,
I didn't want,
I didn't want him to see me,
one of them just,
I'm that kid,
dude.
I'm so,
and my dad would always tell me that,
you know,
you're never going to be nothing.
You're never going to do good.
You never go.
And so I'm that kid.
So that's still fucks with you owe it to come from,
no,
it,
I'm reminded of it.
I read,
I think about that when people tell me all your grades CT or you ever,
Oh man,
I'm,
I come from,
I'm you man.
I,
I wash dishes,
I cut grass,
I pump gas.
Um,
those people,
you know,
I bust tables as a kid.
I was,
I loved it.
All those things.
Yeah.
Though I'm throwing out the people that are saying that I'm great.
I'm my own man.
I'm you.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm not anything other than you.
That's so important.
Yeah.
They are you.
But that they can be someone like youtube.
They put in the kind of time and effort that you put in.
That's the real message.
The real messages.
We all started from nowhere.
I mean,
we all had bullshit jobs.
We all felt like losers.
But through time and effort,
you build a stronger human.
You build a stronger body,
you build a stronger mind.
You build accomplishments and we'll,
and momentum,
and then you look back and you go,
hey man,
I'm not washing tables anymore.
You know,
I'm not a,
I'm not washing dishes.
I'm not cutting lawns.
I'm not digging ditches.
I'm a different person now.
But I used to be
entity's desire not to be there for an actress.
That's what the,
that's the hardest part,
right?
It's to get out of that Rut when you ain't got shit and there's nothing going
on.
To have faith then is so difficult to have faith when you're successful.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
It was a vet.
She had been successful for a walk.
Once you got faith,
just keep doing what you're doing is absolutely right.
It's like you already got up the hill.
Now you're just coasting.
You're just rolling down the hill.
Everything's great as the all smooth sailing.
The hard part's getting up that fucking hill,
and especially if you've got a dad you're hiding from,
especially if you feel like you're a loser.
You're never really had anything in your life that you could look back on and
say,
hey,
I was really good at that.
You know,
and that's a lot of people out there listening to this.
There's so many people that are in that,
that starting point,
like the people that come up to you and say,
what do I,
I don't know what to do.
What should I do?
How do I do it?
How do I get going?
But you're going to have to figure it out one foot in front of the other.
You're going to have to have to find a thing and keep working at it and get
better it.
That's one of the things that I liked so much about martial arts,
to let anybody in anybody in and then from that,
from learning how to do that,
you get better and then you realize it's,
am I going to get better at anything because it's so the first time I ever did
you do.
So I remember just being manhandled.
So bad going,
man,
I'll never be good at this.
This is terrible.
I'm fucking awful at this and this is,
I had already been a black belt in taekwondo and I already kickboxer and did a
bunch of shit and I was like,
I can't believe I'm starting from scratch again.
But that at least I knew then that I already done that before I'd already
started from scratch.
So I had some experience and started from scratch.
I'm like,
Oh,
I have to do is just put in the time and the effort here to get better.
Damn,
that's for everybody.
Just find a thing,
everything.
And if you find a thing like a particularly martial arts,
because you get belts and ranks and then you could see how you're doing with
opponents,
especially Jujitsu.
I liked that when the bolt's cause you don't get in Hit,
you know,
I think there's so many people that in,
especially if you go to a bad gym in the early days,
people are going to tune tune you up,
they're going to beat you up.
You could get some real damage would be scourged lot of people.
Yeah.
But if you could just find a thing and work hard at that thing,
you'll realize through that thing that you can get good at anything with time
and effort.
Don't have anything with that.
I mean,
if you pick the thing,
yeah.
Pick thing,
pick up calls to you,
whatever calls to you.
Yep.
They decide to change to,
to,
to not,
uh,
to change those circumstances,
whatever they might be.
Yeah.
As long as you have,
you have to have that.
These are the will to change their circumstances.
That's actually start right there,
man.
Yeah.
How bleak it mixing,
but if you have the will,
the desire to change it,
they are just starting point.